as predicted the night went to the right
and Georgia Maloney wasted no time in
addressing her supporters and Italy
when this night is over we will remember
that this is a new beginning from
tomorrow on we will have to show what
our values are worth if we are called to
govern and Lead this nation we will do
it for every single Italian with the
goal to unite these people because our
biggest goal in life is to make sure
that Italians are finally proud again to
fly our flag High
sure
polls opened at 7am all in all 16 hours
of voting
there's been a steady stream of people
coming to vote throughout the day
despite the rain and even though most
people are not telling us who they voted
for what is clear is that opinions are
very strong on both sides
I'm voting because it's a duty and a
right that we finally can express we
don't have many rights left so I will
vote in the hope that Italy will come
out of this swamp in which we are stuck
I'm hoping for change for a really big
change because we really need it I'm
terrified that there will be changes
because what's happening is really an
earthquake in my opinion
it's been a divisive election not only
raising questions of what will change
inside Italy but how Italy will present
itself abroad the main challenge
eventually for Maloney as prime minister
would would be to be accepted by the
main European countries as a credible
and reliable partner otherwise if things
will go wrong or if Melania will push
too hard on a far right agenda well
there might be of course very soon some
promise for Italian political stability
Italian economy and as well a
relationship with the EU might be
troubling
there will be weeks for political
consultations and appointments before
the Italian president Sergio matarella
appoints a prime minister
but that seems to be all but a formality
Georgia Maloney is set to be Italy's
first female prime minister the question
then what will her Italy look like
Stephanie Decker Al Jazeera Rome